(audience cheers)
- You got your own couch.
You got your very own couch.
- I know.
- And we complimented
your outfit with the colors.
- I know.
- It wasn't even planned.
- [Rachel] It was planned.
- Oh my gosh. Welcome
to the show everybody.
- Thank you.
(audience cheers)
- All right, so what was
your first experience
with "The Hunger Games"?
'Cause y'all are quite young
and I remember reading
the books a long time ago.
So what was your first experience?
- Yeah, mine, I didn't
read the books originally,
which ended up being a blessing on this,
so I didn't get ahead of myself.
But I went to see them
with my family growing up,
every weekend they came out,
and then we went to the London premiere
a couple of weeks ago,
a couple of days ago,
God, time is like a whirlwind in my head.
And I got to introduce
the film and look up,
and they were in the back row
and got to kind of dedicate--
- Oh, your family? Oh!
- Dedicate it to them.
So it was like a full circle moment.
- That's super cool. What
was your first experience?
- Similarly to Tom,
it was kind of a bonding experience
for my mom, my sister, and myself.
And we would always go
to the Barnes and Noble
releases of the books.
And then the Thursday night
screenings of the movies.
And so, this whole experience
has been very surreal
and strange and weird. (laughs)
- What about you, Josh?
- Yeah, well I was a terrible student.
(audience laughs)
- Lead with that. Okay. (laughs)
- There was a semester
I had pretty bad grades,
so I had to give up a lunch period
so I could go to the library
and like do study hall.
We had a really good librarian there
that gave me "The Hunger Games" book.
No, he was lovely.
He gave me "The Hunger Games" book
and he was like, "Read this,
and I promise reading's fun.
It's like a good thing that," you know,
"it's good for your brain and it's fun."
So yeah. So then I read it.
And it was, I mean, to his credit,
it was the first book I ever
read that I couldn't put down.
And it really kind of jump-started
recreational reading for me.
- Just takes that, right?
Yeah.
- Yeah, so it's kind of,
it's got a formative place with me, so.
- Oh, that's so cool.
Now you're in the movie.
(audience laughs)
Hunter, what about you?
- I just remember it being
like the cool book to read
in school, you know?
In middle school.
So I ended up picking it up
and just became obsessed immediately.
Yeah, and went through all three.
And then, yeah, and the
movies started filming
in North Carolina too,
which is where I was.
So we were like,
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- hearing about it filming.
And we were like, (squeals)
we should go be extras!
- Did you ever, I was gonna say,
did you ever try be an extra?
- No, but we wanted to.
- Oh, well you skipped extra, didn't you?
There you go.
- Yeah!
So Rachel, I found this crazy.
So you actually had to turn
down the role at first, right?
- I did.
- Yeah.
- I had just moved out to
London when I met Francis
for the first time, our director.
And he was so keen on me doing the part,
and it was such an honor
'cause I was such a fan of
the book and of the character.
And when he said that we
were shooting in Poland
and in Germany, and I had only
been in London for two weeks
and I missed my family
and my friends and everything.
- Yeah, stability.
- He said that my face turned white
and he knew immediately
I wasn't gonna do it.
And then I kind of caught my
second wind working out there.
I made a lot of friends and
I felt like I could do it.
And I felt confident in
my ability to carry on
for the next six months without my family.
And I'm really glad I did it.
I'm really glad I changed my mind.
- That's incredible.
First, I mean, not to down youth,
I just mean it's incredible
for someone so young,
I was so stupid.
I said yes to everything.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, even when I was worn
out, walking pneumonia,
I still was like, "Okay, I can do it.
I can do it."
That's so smart. I found this crazy.
But I didn't know y'all
were dating before,
but you, did you know that
she had turned down the role
whenever you accepted the
role, like you got the role?
Did you know that?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean we had talked about it
'cause that happened a lot
further,
- Earlier, yeah.
- earlier than--
- Than when you started auditioning.
- Yeah, 'cause I started auditioning,
by the time I started auditioning,
it was a pretty quick turnaround.
Like I sent in the tape and
then I got the callback.
And then a couple days after
that they offered me the role.
And it was really one of those things
where I was like, no way, you know?
Like I didn't, I don't know.
It's such a huge revered
piece of like pop culture.
I was like, "Oh, this is cool.
Maybe they'll see me and
they'll put me in something else
that they're working on," you know?
But they gave me the role.
- Yeah, that's smart too
though, yeah.
- And then I pretty much
immediately called Rachel.
I was like, "That thing
that you were gonna do,
I'm gonna do it."
(audience laughs)
So--
- And then she was like, "Well wait."
- I'm pretty sure we ended up
like officially saying
yes on the same day too.
'Cause I remember that
FaceTime call, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's
cute. Oh, that's cool.
- Yeah.
- But I heard that you
had, wasn't it like a very,
no, no, I'm sorry, it was you.
You had the interesting chemistry read.
- Oh!
- Whenever,
because a heat wave was happening
and you had no AC and you were (chuckles).
- So I live in Brooklyn and there was a,
it was last, when was it?
Last summer? Beginning of last summer.
Yeah, and there was this
massive, unprecedented heat wave.
And I lived in a little
shoebox apartment in New York
as you do,
- As you do.
- as you do when you live there.
And I had these old AC units
that all just broke the
day of our chemistry read.
And I'd been told I already had the job,
but I went into that
audition so sweaty, literally
and metaphorically,
sweaty, and emotionally,
that and I went in, I was
like, "I'm gonna lose it.
I'm gonna lose the job
that I've already got."
- Because of the heat wave.
- Because I'm just sweating,
I'm dripping, I can't remember the lines.
I'm like (mumbles).
- 'Cause you're on Zoom
and you're like trying to keep it cool.
- Yeah, I'm trying to keep it cool
and collected
- Beads of sweat.
and you know, I've already
jumped through all the hoops
there are to jump.
So I was like, I've got this.
And then I thought I hadn't.
And then the minute we got on together,
it was like instant magic
and Rachel sang and suddenly I forgot--
- Did she lean in and
start sweating with you?
Just to be nice.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's how empathetic an
actor Rachel Zegler is.
- Empathetic sweating.
- Like she saw the beads
and she just beads herself
- I've got you, boo.
- of sweat. (laughs)
- That's so sad.
And of course like just the universe,
you're like, sure, today.
Can you explain, everybody,
I'll go down the row,
but like explain your characters.
- Yeah, so I played Coriolanus Snow,
who fans may remember from
the original franchise films.
- [Kelly] Horrible man.
- Horrible then, 64 years later.
I play him as an 18-year-old.
So he is a lot younger and
a little more innocent,
at least at the beginning.
And then he meets Lucy Gray
and his heart is on the line
and that challenges
everything he thinks he knows
about control and power and by the end,
he's a very, very different man.
- Hell yeah, he is.
- [Tom] Hell yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, what about your character?
- I'm Lucy Gray Baird.
I am the girl tribute from District 12
and I get assigned a mentor in Coriolanus,
and there's a bit of
a romantic connection,
but with a lot of asterisks after that
where you try to figure out
if she's clinging on for love
or self-preservation or both.
And there's a really cool dynamic
between her and in the
games, and she also sings.
So there's that.
- I know, I love the
singing in this, obviously.
I'm a fan.
Well Josh, tell everybody
about your character.
- Yeah. I play Sejanus Plinth.
He is one of the mentors,
but originally he's from the districts.
So he has a real hard time reckoning
with "The Hunger Games".
He's very vocally against it.
He's kind of the moral
compass of the plot.
And he meets a lot of
adversity because of it.
- Have you've done that before?
Have you told someone that?
That was a very good synopsis.
- Once or twice.
- Yes. Hunter, what about you?
- I play Tigris Snow, who is
Coriolanus' cousin technically,
but they're kind of more
like brother, sister,
also kind of like mother
father for each other
because they've been
taking care of each other
since they were wee little children.
So yeah.
- Yeah.
I love, yeah, I love y'all's dynamic.
So wait, you two actually
bonded, Hunter and Tom,
off screen, right?
Y'all go like dancing, right?
- I mean, Berlin.
- We were in Berlin and--
- [Kelly] Went to some clubs.
- Hunter and I have a shared
love of moving to music
a little bit.
So she's way better than I am.
- I was gonna say, you
called it moving to music,
which means leads me to believe maybe,
you're not a great dancer.
- Moving to music, yes.
Exactly.
In my head, I'm just
like move to the beat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Hunter's way better.
- That's awesome.
- But I learned a few moves from her,
you know, she's great.
- That's awesome. Just to get to hang out.
I love Berlin. Did you love it?
- Oh my God, it's the best.
And I love techno so much.
And, it is also great
because you can kind of,
it's a space where you don't,
it's not like you dance with other people.
Like you can really be in your own zone,
but every once in a while you
share a moment with somebody.
And there's like this one moment,
I think where I just
remember looking over to Tom
and then he looks at me and
he's got the biggest smile
I've ever seen on his face.
And he's going.
- This is great.
(everyone laughs)
He's moving.
- Yeah.
- Oh no.
- He's moving.
- He's moving to the music.
- That is me moving to the music.
(everyone laughs)
- I love this song.
It's like, I've always wanted to do those,
I don't know if you've ever done it.
You put headphones on, they do it
a lot of house music.
- Silent disco!
- Yes!
- That's a big thing in England.
I don't know why,
- I've really always wanted
to do it!
- but we love
the silent disco.
I think it's 'cause
we're all very inhibited,
embarrassed people, so we can just--
- I'm not,
I'm a very open person.
- No, in England, I mean.
- No, no, but I'm saying,
but I would love it because
I think it's kind of nice
because sometimes it's annoying,
you go out dancing and
then someone's annoying you
and you're like, I didn't
come here to dance with you.
I just came to dance with me.
- Came here to move to the music.
- Yeah, to move like this, like Tom.
So there we go. Uh, uh.
It's like a fast one.
I've always wanted to do that though.
I'm so jealous that y'all
have done that. Oh my gosh.
Anyway, so I found this funny.
I didn't know that y'all were dating
and then I found out that
you actually passed notes,
this is your thing, which I
think is kind of incredible
and so super cute high school.
But you pass notes on set.
- Yeah.
- Not just to you, like,
you just, you pass notes.
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well I was doodling one day
in my little academy notebook.
- [Kelly] You just slide
it in? You just like.
- Yeah.
- There he goes.
- [Josh] So Rachel, as you can see, she--
- [Rachel] I think it's
something cute and then...
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] You're like, "Aww."
- [Rachel] Something silly.
- She told me to draw her as a flower.
So, you know, I did this really
crude drawing of this flower
with a little smiley
face on it and some legs
and like just handed it to her.
But you know what, I'm glad
that that became such a story.
'Cause afterwards I got
kind of into drawing.
I feel like I got a lot better.
- He's really harnessed his ability.
- Yeah, and I actually made you something
earlier.
- What?
- Yes, I found out that your
favorite animal is a dog.
You really like dogs, right?
- I love dogs.
- So in the same vein of of this,
I decided to draw you as a dog.
- Did you draw me as a dog?
- [Rachel] It's amazing. He's so talented.
Make sure you show--
- So this is kind of...
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- [Rachel] You have to explain it.
(Josh stammers)
- Like you're such a great team,
she set that up so well.
I was like, okay.
- He told me before.
- So, but there's a lot
of nuance to this drawing,
as you see also 'cause you're a singer,
so that you're barking, there's little--
- [Kelly] It is in a musical note.
- [Josh] Yes, that's right.
- [Tom] Kelly, you know the
really scary part of this?
The really scary part is
this is after he got better.
- This is after he got better?
(audience laughs)
Well Tom, I didn't know this,
but Julliard, you went to
Julliard just like Viola Davis.
- Yes.
- Who was who by the way
is so scary in this movie.
That is like, how she said the word dull.
I almost peed my pants.
I was like, don't piss her off.
Anyway, but I didn't know
that you both went there.
I knew she went there, but I
didn't know you did as well.
That's amazing. Did y'all--
- Yeah, we weren't in the same class.
- Obviously.
(audience laughs)
- Different generations.
But I didn't know that
you both went there.
I just thought that was
kind of a cool thing.
- We did.
- That's an amazing thing
that you did in your life
that you both have in common.
- Yeah, I mean it's the
reason I ended up in New York,
which I'm very grateful for.
But it's kind of how we bonded on set
was like talking about, you
know, our shared stories
and weirdly found out
that we have like some of
the same teachers years apart
that have stayed there.
- Really? I was gonna ask that.
- Yeah, one of our
movement coaches in school
was the same teacher,
so he'd just been there his
entire existence I guess.
- Wow. That's really cool.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
Did you ever actually get
to meet Jennifer Lawrence?
Anybody here for that?
- I did.
I think I'm the only one. I did.
We were at the Paris Fashion
Week for the Dior show
only a couple weeks ago.
And, and I didn't want to be weird
and I was just kind of psyching
myself up to talk to her
and she was so unbelievably kind.
And in that clip she's actually saying,
let's do another photo
where I'm strangling you,
saying you'll never take my part.
(everyone laughs)
And that is exactly
what I wanted from her.
- I love that about her.
She seems like the same
offscreen and onscreen.
- Truly.
- That's amazing.
That's a cool thing, like working with,
there's so many people in this movie too,
like Viola, that's just amazing
to be able to work with too.
Do you get nervous in scenes
with people like that?
- Yeah, I mean, especially
when you see Viola's costume,
when she comes in with that fake iron.
- Dude, she's scared--
- Everything. It's kind of terrifying.
But then she breaks for lunch
and she's the funniest
person in the world.
We were just with her this morning.
She's so funny.
- She's so funny.
- She immediately cuts
through any intimidation.
She's great.
- Oh, I love that.
Awesome.
- Yeah.
- Well, what was your
reaction to the film,
like when you first saw it?
I'll start with you.
- Yeah, I mean I was kind
of, I was blown away.
I have this thing when I see myself
where I don't believe it's me.
Like I think it's someone else.
I have like a total disassociation
from the person on the screen.
- It's 'cause you're good.
That's good.
- Thank you.
I think it's 'cause I'm mental.
(everybody laughs)
- [Kelly] But we're gonna go with good.
- We're gonna go with good.
- Unpack that later.
- [Tom] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What about you?
- I was just, I mean
there's this sense of relief
even if you never had a shadow of a doubt
that the movie was gonna be good.
But we filmed for such a long time
and this movie is
separated into three parts
within the movie.
And it felt like we were
filming three different movies
while we were working.
'Cause it felt like coming
of age, high school,
also the Hunger Games,
also war, also this,
and all of a sudden it just,
it came together in such a beautiful way
and it was just kind of this,
oh, this is a really special
thing we have on our hands.
- Oh, that's cool.
- We saw it together,
what did you think?
- Yeah, well, I mean,
I don't know if you
remember my first reaction,
but like, I think I watched the movie,
the credits were rolling,
and I sat there for a second
and I was like, "I think
I'm gonna keep working."
- Aw, I love that.
(audience applauds)
That's good because it looks
so great. It was so great.
It's something that people
are really gonna get into.
Yeah. That's awesome.
What about you, Hunter?
- The first time I saw the screening,
I know it happened because
it was with you guys,
but I complete, I have no
recollection of seeing it.
(everyone laughs)
I don't know, I think maybe
I went out the night before
and we were just like, still going.
- [Tom] Were you moving to music?
- What?
- Were you moving to music?
- Doing this with Tom.
- Were you doing Tom's move?
Were you utilizing--
- I don't know, I don't remember.
But I had to set up a second
screening a few weeks ago
before press started
because I had literally no
recollection of seeing it.
But I was there, right?
- All I have to say,
is what an amazing night before.
Like that must have been
an incredible night before,
if it has the aftermath
of not remembering.
- Yeah. I'm not insane.
- Yeah.
Well, and also it's, I don't know,
it would be weird to see
yourself in something so epic.
Like something so big too.
I would be a little removed
from that I think too.
"Billy The Kid," there's
a new season, right?
- Yes. Yeah.
The first half of season two aired
the beginning of the winter this year.
We're we're going back to film
the second half of season two
because of the SAG strike.
We got shut down.
So that will be out early next year.
It's a really fun job. I
really like riding horses.
- I was gonna say, are
you a natural on a horse?
Do you like it?
- So I first started
riding when I was a kid,
fell off after two lessons
and didn't get back on.
And then I started again two
years ago and now I love it.
Oh, there I am with Bill.
- Boy with a horse.
- That guy.
- That's my horse, Bill.
He has a weepy eye.
- [Group] Aw!
- He's like perpetually
crying for some reason.
And it's not because of me,
I promise.
- Josh should draw him.
- Yeah, Josh, next challenge, Josh
is draw me with Billy.
- He kinda did with my dog.
- Yeah, wasn't that what that was?
It's kind of a blanket animal.